merci merci paris shirt parisienne cher
parisien aujourd'hui vous m'avez accordé
votre confiance pour être à nouveau
maire de paris les circonstances
exceptionnelles de qui entoure ce
deuxième tour de l'élection municipale
rendre ce moment très particulier
je veux remercier l'ensemble des
citoyennes et des citoyens qui se sont
déplacés aujourd'hui malgré la crise du
coronavirus ainsi que toutes celles et
tous ceux qui se sont mobilisés pour que
cette élection puisse se dérouler dans
les meilleures conditions
par cet acte vous avez montrer notre
attachement votre attachement à notre
démocratie car au delà des circonstances
le débat démocratique a eu lieu et les
électeurs ont tranché
vous avez choisi l'espoir vous avez
choisi le rassemblement vous avez choisi
un pari qui respire un pari plus
agréable à vivre une ville plus
solidaire qui ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin
le remercier david d'elia ainsi que
toutes les forces qui se sont unis dès
le premier tour autour de notre projet
et qui ont permis de constituer cette
alliance écologique sociale humaniste
pour l'avenir de paris ce soir je veux
également salué agnès buzyn et rachida
dati qui ont su mener campagne en
défendant leurs convictions j'espère que
nous pourrons travailler ensemble malgré
nos différences dans l'intérêt des
parisiennes et des parisiens
car être maire de paris c'est être mère
de toutes les parisiennes et de tous les
parisiens
je souhaite que toutes les forces qui
oeuvrent au service de nos concitoyens
soit impliqué dans la transformation de
notre ville rendue d'autant plus urgente
par la crise que nous traversons nous
expérimenterons au cours de ce mandat
d'autres manières de faire vivre la
démocratie parisienne afin de donner le
goût de l'engagement à celles et ceux
qui aiment leur ville
cette victoire a du sens parce qu'elle
est collective je veux saluer ce soir
tous les nouveaux élus parisiens
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
politique ce mandat d'élu local est la
plus belle des responsabilités les
parisiennes et les parisiens auront au
cours des six années qui viennent besoin
de nous avec mon équipe nous serons là
je suis particulièrement ému ce soir je
pense bien sûr à toutes celles et ceux
qui m'ont permis de devenir la femme que
je suis je pense à ceux qui m'ont
inspiré je pense aux parisiennes et aux
parisiens qui m'ont toujours soutenu
je pense à mes amis à ma famille
je pense à mon père arrivé en france
avec la république en idéal et qui
voulait que ses filles le réalise
je crois qu'il serait heureux
aujourd'hui fier que sa fille à son tour
porte l'idéal républicain pour
l'ensemble des parisiennes et des
parisiens
[Applaudissements]
votre conscience m'oblige
avec vous nous bâtirons le pari de
demain un pari qui donne les moyens à
ses services publics pour qu'ils
puissent exercer leurs missions en
particulier pour la santé des
parisiennes et des parisiens
un pays qui permet à chacune et chacun
de changer sa manière de vivre de mieux
se déplacer de mieux s'alimenter avec
comme valeurs communes
le respect de notre environnement un
pari solidaire qui aident celles et ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin
un pari de la différence qui combat
toutes les discriminations
un pari qui donne une véritable chance à
sa jeunesse et qui lui donne les clés
pour agir
nous serons là avec eux pour leur donner
les clés
un pari qui accompagne toutes les forces
vives de notre ville pour soutenir
transformer notre économie faire
renaître ce pari que nous aimons tant ce
pari que nous avons en commun c'est ma
vision de l'action politique
un engagement sincère une responsabilité
entière être à la hauteur de la
confiance que vous avez placée en nous
pour cela j'aurais besoin de vous car
tous ensemble nous pouvons changer les
choses et bâtir notre avenir un avenir
en commun et croyez moi
croyez moi cet avenir sera à la hauteur
de nos espérances
alors vive les parisiennes vivent les
parisiens
vive paris et merci voilà anne hidalgo
qui vient de s'exprimer alors qu'elle
serait réélu avec 5 52% des voix dans la
capitale selon les premières estimations